back to today though now we were talking
earlier in the show about the flooding
that's affected many parts of the United
Kingdom and it comes as we've seen more
and more extreme weather so fittingly WA
jall now by the green party's co-leader
sean barie thank you for being on the
program well the Environment Secretary
said that we need to get used to these
extreme weather events is it going to
become the norm it is going to become
the new normal climate change isn't any
longer approaching our door it's come
through the door it's in our kitchens
it's in our living rooms and we are
going to see more and more flooding
events like this if we don't act much
more quickly to deal with the root
causes of this which are fossil fuels
carbon emissions the failure to deal
with climate change emissions throughout
the years has led to this getting as bad
as it is if we're going to stop it
becoming worse and worse and worse we
have to take absolutely drastic action
and do the kinds of investments that we
were talking about during the general
election in London at the moment we've
got the the Mayor of London putting
forwards
50 million pounds for a green agenda
that's not very much we're proposing
tomorrow in the budget to triple that
within London and we can do that
reasonably easily within the mayor's
current plans but I mean I'm standing
for mayor if I were mayor I'd be able to
do an awful lot more but the real power
for this lies with the government I mean
the government gets to realize the
health benefits the government which is
they're now putting into the flooding
risk assessments they're going to look
at the health benefits the government if
it acts can help save those health
benefits realize them within the
extractor and so put it a lot more money
if we don't see this enormous action the
green New Deal's the investment in
climate action that we're asking for
then we are going to see more and more
floods and and that's just the start of
the wider climate chaos I mean it's a
long-term strategy it's not really going
to give much comfort for those people
who have seen no any short-term right we
have seen flood defences funding cut
beyond below what was promised in 2015
and particularly not focused into the
right areas not looking at vulnerability
but looking at like you like you were
saying earlier looking at the the house
prices as a big factor which obviously
leads to places not getting the flood
defence money they deserve and it's
really nice to see the Environment
Minister actually talking there about
natural flood defenses this is something
the graves have been talking about for a
long time we always look to the to the
bigger picture and looking further
upstream a more natural less drastic
less expensive things you can do is the
right way to start tackling this to you
were talking there about the kind of
regional disparity do you think if these
floods were happening in London the
government would be doing more I think
they would have convened Cobra I think
there would have been a bigger response
but yeah like I say the investment is
not going into the areas where the most
vulnerable people are it is looking
instead you have potentially population
concentrations but also house prices the
value of property in London my colleague
Caroline Russell on the London
Assembly's been looking at the impacts
on London and when you do add up the
economic impact obviously it's
terrifying for London most of our jobs
in London lie in flood risk areas so we
have to act in London as well and that's
that's what I'm proposing to do as mayor
think you can you can sort of see that
only the greens are the ones you can
trust it's definitely and we've been
thinking about this for 30 okay now the
UK is hosting the big of UN climate
change conference later on this year big
deal of course and can have a look at
what air Boris Johnson it has promised
the prime minister says that there will
be colossal new investments in
infrastructure and science using our
technological advantages to make this
country the cleanest greenest on earth
that's Boris Johnson in December you
must be delighted that this is a prime
minister who is taking climate change
they seriously I mean he will say things
like that periodically but then he'll
also go ahead and approve new apples and
a new motorways and a new you hs2 which
is a very climate damaging scheme
actually and dangerous you cannot take
action on renewable energy so it's
actually I mean it's got a big carbon
budget to build it and and the actual
savings it makes it to the kinds of
journeys that aren't really going to
transform our transport system in the
way we'd like so we would invest that
money in railways but but differently
but yeah Boris Johnson he hasn't been
putting the effort into the cop summit
that's coming up I think when you look
at what France did in the run-up to the
Paris climate agreements that took place
there they
worked diplomatically with immense focus
immense resources for an entire year to
bring people to the point of which they
could make agreements at the summit the
work isn't done at the summit you don't
just book a room you have to do all that
work ahead of time and you can see no
sign of this from Boris Johnson Claire
O'Neill who was sacked as such as the
the chairman of chair of the cop summit
she said that they're miles and miles
away from being ready to do what's
needed at Paris and this is a huge worry
this is the place where we're supposed
to be agreeing the actions that we take
to achieve not going over 1.5 degrees of
warming agreeing actions are actually
harder than agreeing targets this work
needs to be done now it needs to have
been going on for months already the
problem is you polled less than 3% at
the election Boris Johnson has got an 80
seat majority I mean you're not really
winning the argument here are you I
think we won the argument the question
about how we do an election looking
talking to each other or yeah I mean
we're we're extremely popular as a party
a lot of people agree with what we are
saying so in in London last time where
people have two votes
I was the candidate for mayor I've got
the the highest number of second
preference votes of any candidate now we
just need to flip that around it's not
that hard to see how we could get a
green mayor of London that way fixing
our voting system fixing a move seeing
today the House of Lords scandal that's
going on with the amount of expenses
that are being claimed there we need to
fix Parliament fix the way the country
as a whole is governed but in London we
do have a fairer system and we will see
more greens elected this year okay you
were running for London mayor cleaner is
obviously a big concern for lots of
people in London but also in lots of
other cities and towns across the UK as
well what's your plan to tackle it well
today I've announced a very very
ambitious new target that the mayor the
current mayor doesn't have to cut our
traffic levels the amount of miles we
drive by 40% by 2026 that is the kind of
very ambitious target that we need to be
setting if we're going to transform our
city and it's been just about emissions
this is about air pollution and carbon
but it's all
so about the space in our city the
amount of space devoted to car travel to
people driving on the roads is quite a
lot and if we can get that traffic down
we'll be achieving an awful lot now as
if you remember the Olympics during the
Olympics we had for months and months
beforehand a very big communications
campaign that was saying to people think
about the journeys that you take are you
taking two journeys maybe to go swimming
and then go to the shops could you
combine them into one journey could you
travel at different times could you
travel to things that are nearby and if
you think about it like that my target
which sounds really ambitious at 40
percent is actually saying to people
could you remove or reduce the length of
two out of five of your journeys in six
years time this is totally doable a bit
more though then I was people very
nicely yes think that this is this is a
very small part of my transport plan but
it's a target that doesn't currently
have he asks people to shift their modes
of transport and he is investing some
money in transport like walking and
cycling and railways but he is cutting
investment in buses so my plans would
also invest massively in the alternative
so that people have other options but
this this this idea that you just create
a big mission for London you get
everybody on board behind a target the
way we did in the Olympics there's none
of that happening in London at the
moment we see a lot of advertising from
the mayor but it's mainly advertising
him we need to see the advertising that
we sold and run up to the games that
says think about how you travel let's
get behind this target because the
benefits to all of us would be
absolutely huge
just finally while we got you the story
and going around about caroline lucas
saying that she is being investigated
for giving somewhere a tour apartment in
return for a donation of one hundred and
fifty pounds and now she said that she
doesn't believe she's done anything
wrong what's going on i like i say about
those caroline absolutely is clear that
she thinks she has done nothing wrong on
this as i understand it
all the complaints that go through
parliament like that are confidential
and details can't be discussed so in
fact absolutely all i can say but i'm
confident that if Caroline says she's
done nothing
then she has not okay thank you very
much for being on the program today Sean
at berry there